just had through a statement from the
prince of wales uh prince william in
which he pays tribute
to his grandmother
in it he says on thursday the world lost
an extraordinary leader whose commitment
to the country the realms and the
commonwealth was absolute
so much we said in the days ahead about
the meaning of her historic reign
i however have lost a grandmother and
while i will grieve her loss i also feel
incredibly grateful i have had the
benefit of the queen's wisdom and
reassurance into my fifth decade
my wife has had 20 years of her guidance
and support
my three children have got to spend
holidays with her
and create memories that will last their
whole lives
she was by my side at my happiest
moments and she was by my side during
the saddest days of my life
i knew this day would come but it will
be some time before the reality of life
without granny will truly feel real
i thank her for the kindness she showed
my family and me and i thank her on
behalf of my generation for providing an
example of service and dignity in public
life that was from a different age but
always relevant to us all
he adds my grandmother famously said
that grief was the price we pay for love
all of the sadness we feel in the coming
weeks will be a testament to the love we
felt for our extraordinary queen
i will honor her memory by supporting my
father the king
in every way i can
so that is
a statement from the prince of wales
prince william
reacting to the death
of his grandmother
and
i have been told that
he decided to write that message
after her passing
of course the royal family
in so many ways have prepared for this
moment the plans around her death have
been
years in the making and yet it was made
clear to me that he wanted to make sure
that when the time came
he made the most fulsome and heartfelt
tribute to her
and i think what comes across is
the wisdom that he says that he gleaned
from her throughout his life
i think it stands out that he says that
she was by my side at my happiest
moments and she was by my side during
the saddest days of my life
of course as he traveled up to balmoral
on
wednesday
with the rest of the family
he also would have reflected on the fact
that it was there that he was told
of the death of his mother
but also balmoral was a place where they
spent many happy times together but i
think also within that statement he
makes it very clear that
as well as being this remarkable head of
state and as he says we will in the days
ahead look at the historic meaning
of her reign
he also
very touchingly pays tribute
to
his granny saying be some time before
the reality of life without granny
will truly feel real